Quedaros con la siguiente imagen, porque es
una fotografía que a partir de ahora va a
aparecer siempre en los libros de historia.
Lo sabéis, en ella aparece Theresa May, Primera
Ministra del Reino Unido firmando la carta
que invoca el artículo 50 del tratado de
Lisboa, esta es la carta con la que definitivamente
se pone en marcha el Brexit.
Con esta carta, amigos,
se pone en marcha la separación
entre el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea.
“Hace unos minutos en Bruselas, el representante
permanente de Reino Unido ante la Unión Europea
entregó una carta al Presidente del Consejo
Europeo en mi nombre, confirmando la decisión
del gobierno de invocar el artículo 50 del
tratado de la Unión Europea.
La tramitación del artículo 50 está ahora
en marcha y de acuerdo con los deseos del
pueblo británico, el Reino Unido deja la
Unión Europea”.
Ya lo veis, la ruptura es un hecho, ahora
ya solo queda negociar sus condiciones y para
hacerlo hay un plazo de 2 años. ¿Te parece mucho?
Pues aunque pueda parecértelo, lo cierto es que van a ser unas negociaciones realmente duras.
Al fin y al cabo, son muchas las cosas que
hay que acordar para llevar a cabo la separación,
y también muchos los intereses creados.
Podemos decir, amigos de VisualPolitik, que
las consecuencias van a ser enormes y algunas
ya han comenzado a tener efectos, ojo, no
solo fuera de casa, también dentro:
El pasado 13 de marzo de 2017, la Primera
Ministra de Escocia y líder del Partido Nacional
de Escocia, el abanderado de la independencia,
Nicola Sturgeon anunció su intención de
convocar un referéndum de independencia a
finales de 2018 o principios de 2019. 15 días
más tarde, el 28 de marzo, el Parlamento
de Escocia le dio su apoyo.
Sí, así es, amigos, Escocia, quiere hacer
añicos el matrimonio británico y rememorando
las hazañas de William Walllace, su héroe
nacional, lograr la libertad.
Bueno… a decir verdad, no todos los escoceses
quieren la independencia.
Hace relativamente muy poquito tiempo, el
18 de septiembre de 2014, ya hubo un primer
referéndum y los partidarios de la independencia
perdieron. No fue por mucho, pero en aquella
ocasión la unión británica se salvó.
Pues bien, el BREXIT ha causado un nuevo giro
en los acontecimientos y ha vuelto a poner
todo patas arriba, porque los escoceses apoyaron
abrumadoramente el remain, la permanencia
en la Unión Europea.
¿Será este nuevo desencuentro el que finalmente
termine con más de 300 años de unión?
La tierra de las gaitas, el Whisky
y el mítico monstruo del lago Ness. Escocia es una
tierra de verdes montañas, frondosos bosques
y bellísimos castillos casi fantasmagóricos,
que resisten indomables el paso del tiempo.
Pues bien, bañada por las bravas aguas del
gélido Mar del Norte, Escocia ha sido para
la historia moderna mucho más importante
de lo que podrías pensar.
Escocia ha sido, por ejemplo, la tierra natal
de Adam Smith, el padre del libre mercado;
de James Watt, el inventor de la máquina
de vapor clave para la revolución industrial;
y… también de Sean Connery con su Caza
al Octubre Rojo.
“Cuando llegó al nuevo mundo, Cortés quemó
sus naves, de ese modo sus hombres tuvieron
una buena motivación”.
Vamos, que tal vez el capitalismo no hubiese
sido posible sin Escocia, cuando menos, no
hubiese sido lo mismo.
El caso es que en 1707 el viejo reino de Escocia
y el Reino de Inglaterra acordaron unir sus
destinos y crear un parlamento y un régimen
único: el Reino de Gran Bretaña, al que
más tarde se incorporó Irlanda creando el
Reino Unido de Gran Bretaña e Irlanda, hoy
Reino Unido a secas.
De hecho, si os fijáis, la Union Jack es
la suma de la bandera de Escocia, de la bandera
de Inglaterra y de la que era la bandera de
Irlanda.
Escocia ocupa un tercio de todo el territorio,
pero tan solo supone el 8% de la población
de Reino Unido.
A pesar de ser tan pocos, en los últimos
tiempos los escoceses han tenido una presencia
muy activa en la actualidad del Reino Unido.
Y no sólo por el movimiento independentista:
Gordon Brown, por ejemplo, el Primer Ministro
británico entre 2007 y 2010 es escocés.
Pero estoy convencido de que os estáis preguntando
¿Por qué quieren los escoceses romper 307
años de amor?
Veámoslo.
Reino Unido es un país bastante peculiar
respecto a su mapa territorial.
Podemos decir que es un estado formado por
cuatro naciones constitutivas y que cada una
de ellas tiene sus particularidades.
Escocia, Gales, Inglaterra e Irlanda del Norte.
Por ejemplo, Escocia ha tenido tradicionalmente
una identidad propia muy acusada y muchas
diferencias como por ejemplo un sistema legal
propio y un sistema educativo y religioso
también distinto al de Gales o Inglaterra.
A pesar de ello, aquí las decisiones de verdad,
las decisiones de peso, siempre las ha tomado
Londres, que ha tenido la última
palabra en prácticamente cualquier cosa.
Esta situación, comenzó a cambiar en 1997,
cuando mediante referéndum se aprobó una
primera gran descentralización del poder.
Gracias a ello, un año más tarde se creó
el Parlamento de Escocia, qué además empezó
a adquirir competencias en materia de gasto
como sanidad, policía, educación, etc.
Gracias a este Parlamento territorial, amigos,
el Partido Nacional Escoces, el partido que
aboga por la independencia, comenzó a ganar
más y más peso.
Hoy es con mucha diferencia la primera fuerza
política de Escocia.
Pero… volvamos a la pregunta ¿Por qué
quieren tantos escoceses la independencia?
Pues en parte por lo que estamos comentando.
Hay una sensación bastante generalizada de
que Escocia no tiene prácticamente ninguna
o, al menos, muy poca influencia en Londres,
y por si eso fuese poco, encima se da la circunstancia
de que entre Inglaterra y Escocia hay muchas
discrepancias políticas.
Mientras Inglaterra es una zona más de centro-derecha,
Escocia es algo así como un fortín de la
socialdemocracia.
Fijaros, mientras en el resto de Europa
abundan los nacionalismos xenófobos y racistas,
el caso del Partido Nacional de Escocia es
bastante diferente.
“No importa de dónde vengas, lo que importa
es hacia dónde vamos como nación.
Puedes ser pakistaní-escoces; polaco-escocés
o incluso inglés-escoces”
Escocia aspira a convertirse en algo así como
el Arcadia de la socialdemocracia. Sin embargo,
como políticamente tienen poco peso, a pesar
de no haber votado desde hace décadas al
centro-derecha, casi siempre están bajo la dirección de un  Downing Street girado a la derecha.
Y esto es algo que molesta mucho a los escoceses,
porque les hace sentir que carecen de cualquier
soberanía.
Además, el sentimiento popular generalizado
es que Londres se ha preocupado poco por Escocia
y que les han arrebato los ingresos del petróleo
que se extrae en sus costas.
Y, ojo, no penséis que las diferencias son solo respecto  a que partido político votar
o que se quedan solo en el terreno económico, para nada.
Para que os hagáis una idea, las discrepancias llegan incluso a las armas nucleares:
los ingleses dicen sí y los escoceses las rechazan mayoritariamente.
Pero con todo esto, si la ruptura finalmente
llega a divorcio ¿qué consecuencias se pueden
esperar?
Si finalmente, se celebra un segundo referéndum
por la independencia de Escocia y esta vez
gana el sí ¿Qué consecuencias podríamos
esperar?
Por un lado, para el resto de Reino Unido,
muy pocas, prácticamente ninguna.
Puede que algo desde el punto de vista geoestratégico,
pero vamos, nada del otro mundo.
Escocia como decíamos antes representa una
parte muy pequeña de la población y de la economía.
Y, por el otro lado ¿Qué consecuencias tendría
para Escocia la independencia?
Bueno aquí el caso es un poco distinto.
A ver, no hay duda de que Escocia podría
convertirse perfectamente en un país independiente.
De hecho, estaría entre los 20 países más
ricos del mundo.
Ahora bien, puede que el escenario no sea
tan bonito como algunos pintan.
En primer lugar, las cosas han cambiado mucho
desde el anterior referéndum en 2014, empezando
porque el precio del petróleo se ha desplomado.
Hoy esa joya, ese cohete que muchos pensaban
que era el petróleo para la economía escocesa
ya no lo es.
De hecho, como es muy caro extraerlo del mar
del norte, para lo que hay que utilizar plataformas
como esta que vemos, las compañías apenas
ganan dinero y el estado no ve una libra.
Además, como las compañías no ganan dinero
tampoco invierten y cierran aquellas instalaciones
que pierden dinero ¿el resultado?
Muchos despidos y una economía que crece
mucho menos que la del resto del país.
Segundo, y muy ligado a lo primero, el paraíso
socialdemócrata hay que pagarlo y si el petróleo
no da… bueno Escocia tiene un déficit fiscal
de casi el 10%, que puede hoy puede soportar
gracias al dinero que entrega Londres.
Tercero, el Brexit lo ha cambiado todo.
Me explico, Escocia vende a Inglaterra 4 veces
más que a toda la Unión Europea, así que
si se independiza para volver a entrar al
club europeo el resultado podría ser muy
malo para sus empresas y negocios. Imaginaros que para ganar el 25% del mercado perdiesen el 75%.
Vamos que el Brexit es rechazado por los escoceses,
pero puede que al mismo tiempo sea el mejor
instrumento para que el matrimonio continúe,
al menos unos cuantos años más.
Pero como siempre, la única certeza solo
nos la puede dar el paso del tiempo.
Lo que está claro es que el Brexit ya ha
comenzado, Reino Unido será el primer país
en romper y abandonar la Unión Europea.
Aquí, en VisualPoltik, le hemos dedicado
ya unos cuantos vídeos a este tema.
Por ejemplo, si queréis conocer como los británicos
esperan superar su ruptura con la Unión Europea
no te pierdas este vídeo, donde te lo contamos
con detalle.
Pero volviendo al tema de este vídeo, ¿tú
que crees?
¿Veremos pronto un nuevo país independiente
llamado Escocia?
¿Conseguirá este pequeño país superar
la crisis en la que está envuelto?
¿Qué crees que sería mejor para los escoceses,
quedarse o marcharse del Reino Unido?
Esperamos tus opiniones, como siempre nos
las puedes dejar en los comentarios.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo no olvides darle
a Like y suscribirte al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.